wir schauen in die usa donald trump er
twittert wieder wie gewohnt ist seit
montag wieder im weißen haus er sagt es
gehe ihm gut mit der entlassung aus dem
krankenhaus scheint der gesundheitliche
ausnahmezustand nach seiner erkrankung
vorbei zu sein normalität zeigen diese
bilder allerdings nicht aus dem weißen
haus hier wirkt alles mehr und mehr wie
eine krankenstation wäre ein krankenhaus
desinfiziert wird hier wie es nur geht
spätestens seit dem trump wieder zu
hause ist und wir wollen sprechen mit
herbert bauernebel mir jetzt
zugeschaltet aus den usa herbert ehsan
die desinfektions bemühungen im weißen
haus breitet sich der virus weiter im
weißen haus unter den angestellten aus
das sind tatsächlich bilder wie aus
einem hollywood katastrophenfilm
menschen in hartmanns schutzanzügen die
eben den westring desinfizieren
besonders dass im presseraum der
möglicherweise am meisten infiziert ist
es wurden jetzt in den letzten stunden
keine weiteren infektionen bekannt der
letzte war der berater steven müller der
ebenfalls am karower virus erkrankt ist
das wurde am gestrigen tag ab verlautet
allerdings wird gerechnet dass es
weitere infektionen geben wird
besonders stark ist dieser cluster auch
rund um die pressesprecherin kilometern
hänni
die ja selbst mit dem krone was ihnen
infiziert ist dafür weitere ihrer
mitarbeit dass ihm infiziert und
natürlich groß ist die angst bei der
presse dass ich hier einige weiteres
korrespondenten hier angesteckt haben
könnten schauen wir auf den 8
jetzt die deutschen nacht da gibt es
dann jetzt wieder das tv duell um den
posten des vize-präsidenten
dort duellieren sich amtsinhaber mike
pence und kamelle harris da kannst du
eigentlich nur zwei themen geben jump
und corona krone und trump oder erwartet
man noch andere themen
insgesamt steht natürlich ein großer
fahrplan an verschiedenen sachthemen am
programm am papier aber es wird auch
erwartet natürlich dass bei jeder
wortmeldung dieser beiden gegner in
diesem tv duell kamera
was für die demokraten für joe biden
vize präsident mike pence für donald
trump dass beide eben hauptsächlich auch
eingehen werden auf die pandemie in den
usa im allgemeinen und natürlich die
infektion des amerikanischen präsidenten
im speziellen das wird der das große
thema werden
bei dieser debatte und carola
überschattet ja auch dieses tv-duell die
das team von kamala harris hat gefordert
dass eine plexiglaswand zwischen den
beiden probieren installiert wird um
sich so noch zusätzlich zu schützen vor
mike pence benz hat das zuerst abgelehnt
und musste dann doch zähneknirschend
eingestehen dass er den zustimmen möchte
weil das ganze natürlich ein image
debakel geworden wäre dann natürlich die
demokraten sagen die die die regierung
von donald trump sind sind gefahren
träger die die möglicherweise andere
leute ansteckt herbert dir steht ein
langer tag eine lange nacht bevor mit
diesem spannenden duell ganz herzlichen
dank für deine zeit und für deine arbeit
ja wir haben es angesprochen das tv
duell also in der heutigen nacht
natürlich auch live bei bild hier ein
ausblick mike pence gegen kanada harris
er ist republikaner und demokraten
er möchte bleiben und sie will rein ins
weiße haus als vizepräsident
nach der chaotischen debatte zwischen
präsident donald trump und seinem
kontrahenten joe biden folgt mittwoch
nach die nächste spannende redeschlacht
uns bei dem duell zwischen mike pence
und kamalla harris könnte es für die
zuschauer dieses mal etwas mehr inhalt
geben nämlich bei einer richtigen
diskussion
es könnte giftig werden und es wird
sogar eine plexiglas scheibe zwischen
den beiden aufgestellt aber
hauptsächlich um bei den wilden
auseinandersetzungen die korona wie um
zu bremsen
die kandidaten könnten nicht
gegensätzlicher sein fans ist ruhig
zurückhaltend und konservativ er steht
hinter trump harris hingegen gibt sich
stark und energisch was vielleicht doch
mit ihrem job als staatsanwalt in
zusammenhängen
ein streit der beiden könnte der umgang
im weißen haus mit dem corona virus sein
als leiter der kroner taskforce könnte
sich bands für trumps verhalten mit
seiner krankheit und dem corona wir uns
rechtfertigen müssen
harris hingegen könnte erklären müssen
warum sie nach rassistischen vorwürfen
gegen beiden nun doch für ihn arbeiten
möchte die zuschauer können also
gespannt sein auf das duell um das amt
des vize-präsidenten mehr nachrichten
und breaking news nur bei bate schau
dich hier das nächste video an und
vergiss nicht zu abonnieren